to anybody that is digesting red pill
content and content by people that are
telling you to abstain from getting
married to telling you to abstain from
having children abstain from the family
unit that God ordained for all of us to
have while claiming to be Christians you
need to reject these types of people and
watch what you are feeding and letting
go into your spirit because the agenda
is to depopulate the Earth the agenda is
to have people not having children to be
a narcissistic Society where you're only
living for South see it's too much for
you to go out on a whim and love
somebody else it's too much of a risk
for you to have children right so you
just shouldn't do it but that is not
what God says to do and it is demonic
and I rebuke it in the mighty name of
Jesus